Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Mein Name ist Alper Uslogelere.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz-Arzt tätig
und würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich würde gerne so als personische Frage stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Angelika Müller.
Könnten Sie sich auch sagen,
können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Angelika schreibt,
bestabiert sich A,
N, G, E, L, I, K.
Angelika.
Ja.
Und Müller, der Nachname.
M, I, L, L, E, R.
Müller.
Ja, Frau Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre.
Was sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. Mai 1966.
Okay, danke schön.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
68 kg.
Ja, Frau Müller.
Was für Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe so seit einem Tag,
ich fühle mich nicht so wohl.
Mir ist übel.
Ich habe auch schon zweimal gebrochen.
Und es tut mir eben Bauch so weh.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, haben Sie seit einem Tag Bauchschmerzen?
Seit gestern, ja, seit einem Tag.
Ja, gestern.
Wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Ja, so ein bisschen rechts,
rechts so an dem Rippenbogen rechts,
am Oberbauch, mehr rechts, ja.
In der Mitte und mehr rechts.
Können Sie beschreiben,
diese Schmerzen,
Brennende Schmerzen,
Strechende Schmerzen oder Brücken,
was können Sie beschreiben?
Nee, das ist mehr so,
mehr drückend,
Brückender Schmerz.
Ja, streichende Schmerzen,
die gehen wohinaus.
Ja, so ein bisschen zieht das in die rechte Schulter.
Ja, ich verstande.
Können Sie, haben Sie bemerkt,
gibt es ein bestimmter Auslöser
für diese Schmerzen, zum Beispiel nach dem Essen?
Ich habe seit gestern nichts mehr gegessen.
Mir ist so schlecht, ich habe keinen Appetit.
Ich habe nur etwas getrunken,
ein bisschen Wasser und ein bisschen Tee.
Und wegen der, haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit
bei diesen Schmerzen?
Ja, ja.
Mir ist übel und ich habe keinen Appetit
und es tut mir alles weh.
Ja, ich habe verstanden.
Und ich habe das verstanden,
sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen?
Ja, relativ schnell.
Haben sie durchfallen?
Nein.
Nein, das war bisher immer alles in Ordnung.
Aber ich war jetzt auch seit gestern nicht mehr auf der Toilette,
weil ich auch nichts gegessen habe.
Ja, er verstanden.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Appetitl zu genommen?
Ja, ich habe das nicht mehr gegessen.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Appetitl zu genommen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Gewicht verloren?
Nein, das ist gleichgeblieben.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich habe heute Morgen gemessen
und da hatte ich 38,5.
Und ich habe so ein bisschen Schüttelfrost.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Ich merke es nicht.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Ja, heute Nacht habe ich etwas geschwitzt,
aber ich glaube, das kam vom Fieber.
Ja, Sie haben es nicht.
Ich glaube, haben Sie heute Morgen
ein bisschen Schüttelfrost?
Nein, die letzte Nacht war nicht gut.
Ich habe auch mal eine Wärmflasche auf den Bauch gelegt, vorsichtig.
Aber das war noch schlimmer, die Wärmflasche.
Wärmflasche?
Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen Medikamente
eingenommen?
Nein, bisher habe ich noch nichts eingenommen.
Ich nehme noch etwas,
aber ich habe noch etwas mitgelegt.
Okay, haben Sie
eine kranklose Liedung?
Nein, bisher habe ich noch nichts eingenommen.
Ich nehme normalerweise keine Schmerztabletten.
Ich verstehe.
Okay.
Haben Sie
eine Erkrankung?
Was meinen Sie mit Vorerkrankungen?
Leiden Sie an chronischer Krankheit.
Ich habe etwas erhöhten Blutdruck seit ungefähr fünf Jahren, sechs Jahren, nehme ich auch Tabletten ein.
Welche Tablette nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, ich habe hier so ein Zettel aufgeschrieben.
Da steht drauf Metopolul.
Ja.
Wie viel Millikar?
Da steht 10.
Metopolul, 10.
Und zwar eine morgens und eine abends.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Tablette.
Das ist auch ein schwerer Name.
Ramibril, 5.
5 Millikar.
Eine Tablette morgens und eine halbe Tablette abends.
Wie ist es für dich, wenn du dich auf die Tablette geraten hast?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe mich sonst immer gesund gefühlt.
Sehr gut.
Und wo ist sie schon operiert?
Nein, ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Wie ist die Allergie?
Ich habe sie schon aufgerufen.
Meine Kinder sagen immer, ich würde Erdbeeren nicht vertragen.
Aber ich finde, ich vertrachte Erdbeeren ganz gut.
Ich bekomme manchmal einen kleinen Ausschlag am Mund von Erdbeeren.
Wenn ich Erdbeeren esse.
Erdbeeren sehr gerne.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich eine Allergie habe.
Verstanden.
Und laufen Sie?
Nein.
Haben Sie gelauft?
Nein, als Jugendliche mal probiert.
Aber das war kein richtiges Rauchen.
Nein, ich habe noch nicht so richtig gelaufen.
Sehr gut, das ist gut für Sie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber höchstens einmal am Wochenende.
Zum Essen mal ein Glas Wein.
Aber nur 1-2 Gläser am Wochenende, mehr nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe noch keine Fragen.
Haben Sie schon Drogen probiert?
Nein, Drogen kenne ich nicht.
Ja.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Meine Eltern.
Die Mutter, die hat auch einen hohen Blutdruck.
Ist 82 Jahre alt.
Und ist an der Galle operiert worden wegen Gallenstein.
Aber da war sie, glaube ich, so 55 Jahre alt.
Okay, er verstanden.
Ist sie am Leben?
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Der Vater ist vor 2 Jahren gestorben.
Mit 84 Jahre ernte Prostatakrebs.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester, die ist 2 Jahre älter als ich.
Die ist vor 3 Jahren,
musste sie an der Galle operiert werden, weil sie Gallenstein hatte.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich habe 3 Kinder.
25, 22 und 20 Jahre alt.
Und gesund.
Mein Mann hat auch einen hohen Blutdruck, aber nicht so schlimm.
Der ist auch gesund.
Sehr schön.
Was sind Sie vor dem Beruf?
Ich bin Verkäuferin.
Ich muss den ganzen Tag stehen und hin und her gehen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie wechseljahre?
Ja, sind Sie jetzt wechseljahre?
Wechseljahre sind schon fast vorbei.
War sie schon im Ausland?
Ja, haben Sie gereist?
Ja, ich bin in letzter Zeit.
Wegen Corona war ich nicht im Ausland.
Wir sind in Deutschland geblieben.
Das ist gut.
Und sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
3 Impfungen habe ich schon.
Auch diese Booster-Impfungen habe ich schon.
Ja, das ist schön.
Okay.
Frau Angelica.
Frau Müller.
Ich habe wichtige Fragen für mich gestartet.
Und möchten Sie etwas sagen oder fragen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Ich habe diese Schmerzen.
Ich habe sie vorher noch nie gehabt.
Ja.
Es kann sein, Sie haben eine Galenblase Probleme.
Die Angabe geht von einem Galenproblem aus.
Sie haben auch eine Galenprobleme.
Aber ich muss ein Diagnostische Massage durschen.
Ich werde Ihnen dann eine bestimmte Diagnose sagen.
Ich habe eine gute Team.
Sie sind gut.
Vielen Dank.
Dann warten wir mal die Untersuchung ab.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Ich ruf Ihnen gleich auf.
Sie machen jetzt mal eine Zusammenfassung für sich.
5 Minuten.
Dann können wir die Vorstellung beim Oberarzt machen.
Bis gleich.
Oder habt ihr die anderen Kollegen Fragen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Wir sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz-Kala.
Ja.
Ich habe das vergessen.
Wollen Sie Frau Müller noch fragen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Ja, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz-Kala?
Nur ist es leichter, 10 ist stark.
Ja, ich würde schon sagen 7 bis 8.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie war die Fallbund-Konsistenz von Erbrecher Erböchen?
Und dem Erbrechen? Ja.
Das war so schleimig, gelbgrünlich.
Kein Blut.
Okay.
Gut, machen wir jetzt erstmal eine kleine Klaufe?
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da?
Oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da?
Nein, die sind ziemlich dauerhaft.
Also nicht.
Meine Schwester hat immer gesagt,
als sie adäkalen Steine hatte und operiert werden musste,
meine Schwester hatte so richtige Koliken.
Das habe ich eher nicht.
Das ist mir so ein Dauerschmerz.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie gestern etwas Fettiges gegessen?
Vorgestern war ich auf einem Geburtstag eingeladen.
Und da habe ich doch 2 Stücke Sahnetorte gegessen.
Ich weiß eigentlich,
Sahne und fettige Sachen vertrage ich eigentlich nicht gut.
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Bechwerde?
Ja, ich habe es früher gegessen.
Ich habe es früher gegessen.
Hast du früher ähnliche Bechwerde?
Nein, so etwas habe ich eigentlich noch nie gehabt, so ein Schmerz.
Nein, das ist neu.
So, wie sieht es aus?
Ich kann anfangen.
Herr Oberhass, haben Sie gesagt,
ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen.
Okay, habe ich.
Ja, danke schön.
Frau Angelika Münder ist 56-Jährige Patientin.
Die Patientin ist 168 cm groß
und 68 gewischt.
Kilo, ja?
Ja, gewischt.
Und die Patientin sterte sich uns wegen seit gestern aufgetretener
Drückender auf Erhalterabdominergie vor.
Ja.
Diese Schmerzen strahlen
im rechten Oberbau und in rechten Schulter.
Ja, strahlen aus in die Schulter, ja?
Ja, aus.
Und die Schmerzintenz, das liegt auf einer Skala 7 bis 8.
Okay.
Auf einer Skala bis 7 bis 8
und die Patientin klackte über Romythus,
Neuzia und zweimal, die Patientin habe zweimal Erbrötchen.
Ja, okay.
Und die Patientin habe zuerst mal diese Schmerzen gehabt
und bei der Patientin habe wegen dieser Schmerzen
keine Appetit und Insomnia.
Appetit und Insomnia.
Okay, gibt es eine auffällige Vorgeschichte diesbezüglich?
Hat sie so etwas schon mal gehabt?
Nein, das ist so erstmal
und wegen dieser Schmerzen nur gestern Abend
habe die Patientin gehabt.
Ja, gibt es Temperaturen?
Ja, die Patientin, die Patientin habe Fieber auch
und die Temperatur ist 38,5 Grad.
Okay.
Ja, die Nachfrage, die weiteren Fragen wurden verneint.
Ja, gibt es Risikofaktoren?
Ja, die Patientin habe vorgestern
ein fettreicher Essen gegessen
und auch die Patientin, der 48 Programme,
seine Mutter wurde eine Kulistik-Tummi gehabt.
Ja, die Mutter, auch die Schwester.
Okay, die Schwester.
Ja, ihre Schwester, die Schwester.
Und habe eine Kulistik-Tummi auch gehabt.
Ja, gibt es Schwangerschaften in der Vorgeschichte?
Ja, die Patientin habe drei Kinder,
drei gesunde Kinder
und die Patientin, leider,
die Leider an Arterieal-Hipartone seit fünf Jahren
und die Patientin nehme regelmäßig Metaprolose 10 mg,
1,01 und mit Briefe 5 mg, 1,0 halbe Tablete.
Okay.
Die Patientin habe bis dann kein Operiert.
Also keine Voroperation im Kopf?
Voroperation, ja, bis dann.
Und die Patientin habe keine Allergie,
aber manchmal konnte die Patientin gegen Erdbeeren unverträgt.
Okay, okay.
Er ist nicht die Patientin, ist nicht raucher,
sie trinken gelegen, nicht nur wohnende,
ein, zwei, glässe Wein, trinken.
Okay, alles.
Und sie habe keine Drogen probiert.
Okay.
Und ihre Mutter leider an Arterieal-Hipartone,
auch ich habe gesagt,
sein Vater sei an Prostatkarsun und gestorben.
Okay.
Woran denken Sie, woran denken Sie, Herr Kollege,
was hat die Patientin?
Aufgrund dieser Angabe gehe ich für Koleistitis aus.
Koleistitis aus, ja.
Ja, kann man denke ich ausgehen, wahrscheinlich wird sie vielleicht auch Gallensteine haben,
wie ihre Schwester und wie ihre Mutter, drei Schwangerschaften in der Vorgeschichte
ausgehen und zumindest hatte sie ja schon eine gewisse Fettunverträglichkeit beschrieben.
Ja, und was eben differenzialdiagnostisch in Betracht?
Ja, ausdifferenzialdiagnostisch kommen, kommen, kommen, kommen,
kommen, auch akute Pargratitis und Nephrolitiasis in Betracht.
Okay, was spreche gegen eine Nephrolitiasis?
Ja, ne, richtig Schmerzen, Nephrolitiasis gibt es nicht viel, aber...
Wie sagten die Schmerzenstrahlen auch in die Schulter raus?
Schulter aus, es kann sein, ja.
Aber ich denke, differenzialdiagnostisch, Rulkus duodini, Pargratitis, auch Gastitis
Was sind sich die hauptsächlichen Differenzialdiagnostischen?
Ja, Differenzialdiagnostischen, richtig.
Und was wollen Sie jetzt in der Primärdiagnostik veranlassen?
Ja, ich würde gerne erst für Parliche untersuchen, Parliche untersuchen
Und dann sollte ich Abdomenzsonografie durchführen
Und Abdomenzsohn aufnahme natürlich durchführen
Und auch die gibt es, könnten wir ERCP durchführen
Ja, gut, das wäre sicherlich der erste Schritt, ich würde jetzt erst mal untersuchen, Abdomenzsonografie
Und Laborabnahme, natürlich Laborabnahme
Ich denke auch, wichtig ist im Rahmen der Blutabnahme, ihr eine Infusion anlegen
Die Patientin soll nicht mehr oral sich ernähren
Und ich denke, sie wird, wenn sie seit gestern nichts mehr gegessen hat, wahrscheinlich auch wenig getrunken hat
Auch etwas exikiert sein, sie braucht eine Infusion
Natürlich, Sie haben Recht, die Patientin könnte Exikose
Und ich muss einen Zugang legen und ausreichende Flüchtigkeit durchführen
Auch gegen Schmerzen sollte ich Energie-Ticker verabreichen
Auch, ja auch, der Patientin habe Fieber, ich sollte Antibiotische Therapie durchführen
Mindestens nach Erhalt des Akutlabores je nachdem, wie eine Entzündungskonstellation ist
Mit Leukozylten, CRP, Antibiosenerwägung ziehen
Und eine ERCP würde ich jetzt auch erst mal sagen, wäre jetzt erst mal etwas nachgeordnet
Im Augenblick wäre es erst mal wichtig, eine Basisdiagnostik, Patientin möglichst den Schmerz zu behandeln
Flüssigkeit zu geben und gegebenenfalls Antibiotese
Ja, richtig
Ja, das bin ich wieder einverstanden, würde ich so machen
Ja, danke schön
Gut, ja, finde ich, das haben Sie gut gemacht
Danke schön
Achten Sie drauf, wenn Sie das Schildern und die Anamnese machen, nehmen Sie möglichst nicht so oft die Hände vor das Gesicht
Häufiger gemacht und dann so runtergeschaut zu Ihrem Block, lassen Sie die Hände ruhig unten
Dann versteht Sie die Patientin besser oder der Oberarzt, ist besser die Hände nicht vor das Gesicht zu machen
Ja, ja
Vielen Dank für Ihre Tipps
Manchmal ist es natürlich eine Stresssituation
Ja, erst mal, ich gehöre nächstermal nicht
Ich sage dann, dass, wenn mir etwas auffällt, dass Sie das vielleicht etwas abgewöhnen sollen
Man ist, glaube ich, ganz gut
Ja, danke schön
Ansonsten finde ich gut, Sie haben sich auch nicht aus der Ruhe bringen lassen
Wichtig ist, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, auch von der Patientin nicht nachfragen
und lieber den Namen stabilieren lassen, ja
Das ist wichtig, bevor man vielleicht einen falschen Namen aufschreibt oder so etwas
Und ja, das ist entscheidend
Okay
Vielen Dank für Ihre Tipps
Haben Sie denn schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, sie sind auf der Ruhe
Ein Monat später
Haben Sie jetzt ja noch etwas Zeit
Ich habe da ein gutes Gefühl
Ja, danke schön
Okay